Whether you play the lottery or not,...
...you may be interested to know what and where the world's biggest action is.
According to La Fleur's 2013 World Lottery Almanac,...
...the biggest games worldwide are the lotto-style ones.
More than 110 billion dollars in tickets were sold last year.
Scratch-offs are popular too, generating nearly 76 billion dollars in 2012 sales.
Who's buying all those tickets?
Europeans in general are the biggest dreamers of free fortune.
Of the 113 billion dollars a year spent on lottery tickets on the continent,...
...Italy's largest lottery operator, Lottomatica accounts for 25.1 billion of it.
The biggest per person spenders are from Singapore.
Its residents throw an estimated one thousand dollars each into the pot.
Of course, the winners' circles are always filled with tragic stories,...
...but a few fresh millionaires have managed to survive the curse and do a lot of good.
One British couple has been spreading kindness.
They purchased a prosthetic limb for a young man who lost his leg to cancer.
A Wisconsin winner used their millions to set up a day camp for local kids.